a banda salve salve
tudo bem que vocês bem alimentados
então beleza gente há sete anos se
alguém me falasse que um dia teria um
ted x só quebrada e eu seria uma das
palestrantes com certeza eu não
acreditaria
até porque há sete anos não sabia nem o
que era até x na gente bem como já
falaram meu nome é michele michelle
fernandes sua mãe mulher preta
periférica empreendedora e empresária
comecei minha vida muito cedo a
trabalhar aos 16 anos foi balconista
operadora de telemarketing
fiz algumas faxinas em meu último
emprego de carteira assinada
foi num dia e auxiliar administrativo
o escritório de arquitetura em são paulo
foi muito bacana trabalhar quatro anos
nessa empresa aprende muita coisa que eu
sei aplicou hoje na mesma empresa
só que lá infelizmente eu sofria micro
agressões todos os dias não eram
agressões físicas e sim agressões causa
do tom da minha pele casos de clientes
fornecedores chegarem no escritório e
depois de um longo ano conversando com
ele tratando pelo telefone ele chegar
iam me ver ficar totalmente decepcionado
pela minha fisionomia e ainda escutar
dele falando nossa imaginava
completamente diferente
branquinha magrinha loirinha não está no
lugar errado outra vez uma funcionária
dentro da empresa
todo mundo conversando batendo um papo
ela falar eu jamais deixaria meu filha
com uma mulher com uma mulher negra
nem o gay a se casar um dia eu precisar
de uma empregada com uma babá bem ao
longo de quatro anos e isso foi me
desgasta desgastando muito fiquei doente
e acabou eu sendo desligado dessa
empresa
naquele momento eu prometi pra mim mesma
a partir daqui eu não trabalho mais para
ninguém eu não vou sofrer mais racismo
não sabia o que ia fazer
tinha que fazer alguma coisa não tinha
idéia
calhou nessa época adotar passando pela
transmissão capilar
pra quem não sabe pra mulher negra
passar pela transição capilar é um marco
na sua vida a gente pára de se encaixar
no padrão imposto pela sociedade
realizar nossos cabelos para se sentir
pertencido a um lugar e deixa o nosso
cabelo natural por muitas vezes como uma
história por 26 anos eu não tinha idéia
de como era meu cabelo
a única coisa que eu sabia que ele era
duro difícil de cuidar porque era isso
que as marcas e toda a sociedade falava
pra mim bem passando pela transição
capilar
eu precisava buscar no mercado elementos
que valorizassem a fase que estava
passando essa mulher negra e ponderado
ela precisava nascer eu precisava de
produtos acessórios que valorizar ainda
mais essa mulher
foi aí que eu não me vi no mercado eu
não vi milho no mercado na propaganda
com mulher fora dos padrões
eu não me vi na propaganda com uma
mulher negra e muito menos nos produtos
criados para mim nessa época meu esposo
digníssimo itália
ele trabalhava numa rua teste aqui em
são paulo como carregador de tecido e
ele levava pra mim alguns retalhos de
tecido para fazer os turbantes tudo bem
simples eu passar por essa fase da
transição me sentindo mais bonita
eu pegava fazia uma razão bem simples
tirava foto tinha estava nas redes
sociais
até que certo dia uma pessoa falou pra
mim
nossa que bacana onde você comprou o
turbante
eu olhei pra ele e falei opa tem algo aí
foi que a gente pensou vamos tentar
vamos ver o que ele vai fazer vão raspar
conta pegar toda a nossa grana e vamos
comprar nossas pesquisas foi o que eu
fiz o meu primeiro aporte na butique de
crioula foi de 150 reais
vinte turbantes fiz algumas fotos
amadoras em cima da minha cama
apostei nas redes e comercializar as
amigas e aí fulana beleza é o seguinte
estou trabalhando com turbantes
você já viu cinco anos que eu faço e aí
quer fazer e chamar as pessoas para
curtirem a página
eu lembro quando eu falei pra minha mãe
mãe eu não vou trabalhar mais para
ninguém
eu vou aprender olha aqui os turbantes
ela virou pra mim e não super apoio
falou 'você tá maluca
como assim naquela época fiquei chateado
a loja que é um apoio mas hoje eu
entendo
imagine uma mulher negra que saiu da
cidade do interior de minas gerais
com apenas 12 anos para ser empregada
doméstica em são paulo 12 anos sozinha
foi passando de casa em casa tentando
toda vez buscar algo maior para ela
ganhar mais um dinheiro conquistar
alguma coisa aos 34 anos
ela engravidou de mim mas solo no dia
que eu nasci ela me falava que começou a
sentir as contrações pegou um ônibus foi
sozinha o hospital
no terceiro dia ela saiu sozinha do
hospital com 15 dias de nascido
ela voltou a fazer faxina e ela dizia
que agradecer a deus a todos os momentos
que eu era uma criança muito tranquila
ela dava de mamar e deixava no cantinho
e ela conseguia terminar a faxina na
casa toda sem ter que chorar eu fui
muito muito a gente teve uma união muito
forte na minha mãe
a gente sempre morou no fundo das casas
dos patrões dela das empresas que ela
trabalhava
e eu lembro que minha primeira cama
sozinha longe da minha mãe foi aos 13
anos de idade ela foi sempre de tudo
para que eu tivesse a melhor educação
possível o que ela podia fazer para que
eu não parasse de estudar e me formasse
o ensino médio mesmo eu da minha família
a sua primeira pessoa a completar o
ensino médio era analfabeta sempre se
virou e passou para fora lavou fez
salgado e uma imagem que me marca muito
quando eu falo de empreendedorismo eu
lembro da minha mãe pegando um carrinho
de feira colocando algumas marmitas
dentro e saindo pelos bairros de onde
ela morava para vender suas marmitas
então pra chegar pra minha mãe fala pra
ela olha o seguinte eu não vou mais
trabalhar pra ninguém pra ela era como
se fosse uma afronta como assim eu fiz
de tudo para você estudar pra você
entrar numa empresa ficar nela crescer e
nela se der e se aposenta lá para
empreender por mais que ela fazia isso
não era o futuro pra mim
ok insistir
depois ela acreditou no trabalho ajudou
a gente dentro da empresa com três meses
a gente precisa tomar uma decisão
meu esposo e aí vamos tentar vão parar
ou paravam botavam mercado de trabalho
ele não pouco vamos tentar ver o que dá
três meses
viraram seis meses em seis meses a gente
tinha mais de 10 mil curtidas nossas
redes sociais e já começaram a enviar
nossos turbantes para alguns cantos do
brasil com um ano a boutique de crioula
começou a ser chamada para fazer balé é
fazer workshops de turbantes em algumas
cidades brasileiras que eu tive o prazer
de rodar já grandes partes do brasil com
a butique de crioula
mas tudo sempre com muita luta por
diversas vezes a gente saía do canto da
cidade por exemplo capão redondo
a gente vai fazer um evento na zona
leste que estava muito cheio é um show
de rua tá muito cheio dá para a gente
montar nosso estande mas a gente
precisava fazer alguma coisa e só tinha
ido com dinheiro da condução ea gente
decidiu por ter um poste aqui tem um
poste aqui tem um carrinho de cachorro
quente senti montar um varal aqui dos
turbantes as pessoas vão comer vão
passar pelos nossos turbantes alguém vai
ver esse trabalho foi isso que a gente
fez
fizemos um varal colocamos nossos
urbanos e foi sucesso no final a gente
te comer cachorro-quente bem no primeiro
ano de butique de crioula a gente fechar
nosso faturamento e 120 mil reais
começando com 150 bem crescemos
temos um escritório criamos uma equipe
de cinco pessoas
nada podia tá errado tudo certo
ledo engano né em 2015 eu sofri um golpe
muito duro da vida que foi ter minha mãe
teve uma parada cardíaca nos braços
eu perdi a minha mãe 2015 então em uma
depressão super profunda tentando deixar
as coisas deixa pra lá não vai dar mais
para continuar
não vou conseguir mais pedir meu
alicerce em 2016 em gravidez de uma
menina maravilhosa chamada maria andar e
ela deu forças para continuar o legado
foi gente não posso parar aqui
minha mãe começou uma coisa lá atrás eu
preciso continuar bem em 2016 também não
foi só isso
em meio à crise os concorrentes entraram
muito forte no mercado
um deles é um concorrente filho da mãe
que a china que eles conseguem criar
qualquer coisa gente um dia passeando na
25 de março na bonita lá que está
rolando há 25 tá lá o nosso bico pra
quem não sabe os nossos brincam criações
próprias uma esposa o design da marca
ele faz todos os desenhos e eu vi lá um
desenho que ele ficou a madrugada
inteira fazendo exposto na 25 de março
por um preço mais barato do que o pago
do meu fornecedor
ali eu pensei cara galera fechou a marca
como a gente vai correr concorrer com a
china
sentamos com nosso fornecedor falamos ao
seguinte estão copiando a gente a gente
precisa entregar o melhor produto para
os nossos clientes como a gente vai
fazer
melhoramos nosso trabalho
infelizmente 2016 eu tive que mandar
minha equipe embora
foi muito difícil tive que fechar o
escritório e diminui ele para dentro da
minha casa e um bendito funcionário
maravilhoso comigo até hoje
o lucas arranjou emprego uma padaria
pertinho de casa todo dia que eu ia lá
com a minha mala fazendo os eventos eu
passava na bendita padaria estava lá o
lucas eu falava que merda que eu fiz
cara como sim eu tive que diminuir em
fim de vida que segue e vão continuar
embora continuar
em 2017 começaram
muitas coisas aconteceram muitas coisas
a rolar
eu acho que a resiliência além de toda a
minha família morar na periferia me fez
ver as coisas com uma outra perspectiva
lá a gente consegue construir muitas
coisas com muito pouco a gente consegue
fazer um novo de novo eu tenho certeza
que aqui alguns de vocês já ouviu falar
do carro do ovo porque já o carro da
pizza maravilhoso carro da pizza é roxa
com ele passamos horas da noite
que mancada enfim é maravilhoso e isso
começou na quebrada a gente precisava
fazer alguma coisa pra ganhar dinheiro
para sustentar as suas famílias e dá
emprego para algumas pessoas estavam ao
nosso redor e se espalhou pelo brasil
inteiro
isso me deu muita força para continuar
em 2017
eu participei de um é de um concurso
pela liberty seguros entre mil mulheres
foram selecionadas e mulheres das
mulheres foram selecionadas dez mulheres
e das mulheres uma mulher pra ganhar um
prêmio de 15 mil reais
essa mulher fui eu
em 2018
a gente passou em duas acelerações
dessas duas acelerações além de aporte
financeiro que a gente recebeu para
comprar equipamento melhorar nossos
serviços alugar um espaço melhor a gente
recebeu mentoria com os melhores
profissionais do mercado neste ano de
a gente fechou antes disso o verdão e
recontratou o luca gente eu falei lucas
vem cá e aí cara que eu preciso de você
voltar pra mim ele eu adoro trabalhar
pra vocês pagam o salário que eu tô
voltando
[Risadas]
lucas voltou pra gente bem
em 2008 eu fechei o ano da butique de
crioula enviando mais de 3.000 turbantes
para todo o brasil 5 represente é
representante cinco países angola
portugal suíça estados unidos
fechei o ano dando entrevista para uma
das maiores redes de jornalismo que foi
a bbc de londres
eles foram até a quebrada conhecer a
história e com faturamento de mais de
150 mil reais
há uns pode parecer pouco mas imagina
você empreender de um lugar onde as
pessoas só conhecem pela criminalidade e
começou no mínimo por muitas vezes foi
difícil muita gente parou de pagar
aluguel
mas mesmo assim a gente resistiu em 2019
a gente é abrir um escritório e foi
muito importante para a gente esse passo
porque a gente está cada vez mais
ocupando um lugar na sociedade mostrando
às pessoas que o negro também é lindo e
que os nossos produtos não são só um
turbante
não é só um brinco a partir do momento
que a mulher em rola aquele turbante na
cabeça não há mais o brincar ido
ela levantou o ombro para segurar a
coroa para finalizar
eu só queria dizer
a periferia ela sempre empreendeu a
periferia ela sempre vai empreender mas
agora é diferente
a gente quer pegar nossos produtos e
mandar para outro pra isso
a gente quer contratar funcionários que
são ali da nossa quebrada para que ele
não passe mais 14 horas longe do seu
filho ou chega atrasada no serviço
depois de três horas de um trem lotado e
escute do pa do patrão que não é
problema dele
a gente quer trazer as emissoras de tv
lá pra quebrada não para falar de
chacina mas pra ouvir a nossa história
de sucesso e o principal que é um marco
da minha marca e de muitas marcas
muitos projetos ainda preferir a gente
quer mudar a vida das pessoas
muito muito obrigada gente
[Aplausos]
[Música]